it's that great time of year again yes
the great school supply drive starts
today and rocky stopped by one of our
local smiths food and drug the sponsors
of the segment to learn how you can help
do you see that folder right there is it
bringing you nostalgia does it take you
back to elementary school because it
takes me back and that is what we're
doing we're celebrating our elementary
school students our students across
clark county school district with the
great school supply drive partner
channel 8 and smith of course so chris
with smith why is this partnership so
important to the community um with
smith's we're just
more than just in the grocery business
we're in the people business absolutely
and really we want to um
families welcome us into their
neighborhood and we just want to be part
of the community i love that now let's
talk about the school supplies that we
are you know purchasing for our kids i'm
oh my god i smell crayons i have my
backpack on i love this you can bring
your kids in and help and have them shop
with you for the to help their kids
their fellow peers and students so what
are we getting here at the seasonal
aisle definitely i mean you have your
variety of pens pencils
notebook paper
highlighters
everything that you need to get started
for
the school season i love that you got
backpacks
thermoses lunch pails anything you would
need and these are across clark county
at all all the smith locations and then
what's the process like when people come
in to shop for their groceries they come
into the aisle grab their school
supplies and then what they just grab
their school supplies and then they
bring them up to the check stand and
then um tell the cashier that they are
donating their school supplies for the
grade 8 school supply drive and then
they would put them in the bin there we
go up front at the front of the store
okay perfect and of course you see that
big date right here through the 28th you
have till next thursday to come in and
collect your supplies and donate and
then at the cash registers what do you
guys have here at your location so here
at sky canyon marketplace we have these
set up at every check stand
everything in this little tote here is
under a dollar so everything that we can
get donated out of these boxes will help
our school children here in cloud county
and beyond that you guys are also
helping give food and lunches to our to
our students in need correct correct we
are
also donating a dollar fifty at our
checkout stands
and this goes to help feed one in six
kids in uh clark county uh don't know
where they're gonna get their next meal
and that's the sad reality and we're
just trying to do our part and help the
community absolutely and then you know
on the other hand school supplies bring
these kids joy right and shopping for
them brings you joy too so come on into
your smith
your local neighborhood smith and help
our kids of clark county school district
and last but not least chris in the
spirit of school supply season let's
pick you a backpack okay okay i've got
mine i've got mine right here all right
which one are you going for um i'll go
with this guy
i like your
style we go
all right we are ready come on down to
smith and get your school supplies for
our kids we'll send back to you
eight news now is partnering with smith
and las vegas honda dealers to collect
school supplies for our community
starting today you can drop off
backpacks folders pencils and other
items to your nearby smith's location or
las vegas honda dealer this runs through
july 28th and there's more information
at eight news now dot com now let's
bring in